hello and welcome to this video playing
notables not opposed this big fan thank
you
you don't see the chat here mmm
okay so play play the Slav 92 is a set
line that is actually quite interesting
alright so do I get this back or I have
to move the knight back at some point
but don't want to do it straight away
it's a bit weird he's he's got this
Bishop on on d7 which is not very very
common displacement I wonder maybe this
young Bishop b2 so that if he takes I
can take with the b-pawn hmm and one
idea that ahead in mind was f4 at some
point but come on let's get to get this
back I was getting nervous yeah if they
have those unprotected pieces on the on
the side of the board if five is just a
far more agreeable square for the knight
now I have a fairly standard attacking
procedure with f4 Queen f3 Queen h3 is
going back maybe I can make c5 a little
bit more difficult
okay hey this is just a bit too
I mean it's playing this very passively
and I want to try to punish this yeah
isn't this a big issue now how do you
cover it I got this
okay Bishop f8 then grabbing huge chunks
of material already know that's just
winning winning the house so do I take
on f7 yeah I think I do
I saw a more a sim on g6 our Bishop g6
is also also coming
yeah I don't know here I don't really
see a move now threatening night age six
and it's no play of a move for black
simply Queen f6 yeah
hangs on for the movement something like
this should be fine
really tough to make a movie I cannot
move I cannot move any piece down okay
there was there was nothing really that
you can do and the the opening result
for black was was too a bit too bad
really young after night age for black
has a couple of choices Bishop a form is
probably the most ambitious move but
it's important to know that this is not
that great there's a problem here with
this line when white is threatening to
almost made on c8 winning the hook then
and threatening 96 this is already
pretty bad so this is the best reply
Bishop d7 yeah if you if you want to go
away and play e6 you rather you can
better go to c8 if you want okay so he's
six Bishop d3
yeah 96 yeah this is it's not really
doing much him this is just not a very
harmonious piece placement and now I
decided to get it get it back to the
center and it this is just a super nice
setup why does everything nicely
coordinated and I have good attacking
ideas this is something the route can go
or what I did with with Knight f3 that
was a little bit I wasn't it was I was
speculating that he's not covering
Knight g5 because it was very obvious
somehow that next move was Bishop g7 so
it was a bit bit hope chess on my part
but it's not it's not a bad move you get
it closer to the king side and after
this yeah everything is falling apart
this is also not helping yeah and here
I'm just just winning winning the house
this is an interesting interesting line
it's not not very well-known but quite
quite a playable option for white okay
guys thanks for watching